from screen jumping studio in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
moving by now your host Andy signor
today's episode is brought to you by the
new Samsung Chromebook plus the first
Chromebook made for Google Play what's
up guys welcome to an awesome episode of
movie fights I'm so happy to be here
because we have three amazing
competitors and we're all going to talk
about some spider-man topics and some
other stuff but in honor of homecoming
coming up we have one of the staff
members himself here to talk about it
and two amazing fighters to go against
them stuff including best spider-man
performance best seen in a spider-man
movie but then also non spider-man stuff
like we had as what was the one what
movie if you have someone you that you
know is the one what movie do you want
them to say they they love also if TV
and on all these TV shows happening from
Coen Brothers David Lynch who do you
want to see make a TV series lots of fun
stuff so stay tuned let's get right to
our PI our competitors I'm so happy to
introduce back to the show so happy to
have her the red fury or self plus you
have your book I'm so excited to talk
about backwards and heels coming out the
past present and future of women of
working in film it's coming out this
August yes yeah we should Malone Amazon
but I feel like I've made a huge mistake
going up I let a spider-man just with a
nexus and spider-man hey the red fury
feels like a spider-man character they
can use it embrace it yeah you're going
to do great I'm so excited to have you
Congrats the book I'm so happy I know
all our fans have already been buying
but if you haven't go pre-order one now
next up guys he's from grand Budapest
hotel you've seen them in dope and now
you can see him playing Flash Thompson
in the upcoming spider-man homecoming
Tony Remora hi sorry we're in the Booker
ah Tony I saw the movie and you're gonna
happen and it would be fantastic isn't
that a sigh relief you got a little bit
sometimes like man it just sucks oh no
no I like I read the script so long ago
that I knew that was going to be great
and it's Marvel and it's fantastic it's
also Sony it is awesome which they
greeted us they did just fantastic Amy
I can fight you did a great job I just I
was worried because I'm you know short
and brown and not tall as lunch which is
what my character looks like in the
comics but people seem to be really
lacking you play a real ass it's good
you do a great job at it but then a
likable one yeah you know we want to
have some room to grow
yes penis Parker Miss Parker Oh excited
it's really it's a lot of fun and it was
so fun to you in there watching this
awesome I mean kids epic like it's art
isn't yeah this is a Marvel movie to its
core so weird for me though because I
shot all the high school stuff and then
they shot all the spider-man stuff so
when I saw the movie for the first time
I'm like oh right this is a spider-man
movie there's action yes we got a lot of
stuff yeah you haven't you yeah I want
to spoil it but on the Washington
Monument man yeah I want to punch you
but excited I know fans are excited to
see it they're gonna have a blast man
thank you for coming
you know I've never back she's awesome
Millennium Falcon weekly
so having Nicholson he's getting me make
spider-man letter and yeah Wow I know a
little Ingham attic I know I think I'm
already gonna win just based on this
neither of them based on our higher I
give you the point thank you I'm gonna
take that role with it the episode is
over one already yes well you're there
go guys step it up
um but yeah you're spider-man fan and
you're like the original trilogy here
yeah no yeah exactly Tobey Maguire is
like I can't even
any actor be Tobey Maguire not to like
spoil my answer for the upcoming
question maybe I don't like it we don't
know so yeah maybe mind game I love it
I'm psyching you out yeah well I'm so
excited Malia Falcons on SJ news and
we've recently announced soon to be on
screen junkies main coming soon on the
weekends a couple weeks we have some fun
stuff max landis is going to come by
you're gonna be at d23 talking about
Star Wars and Disney stuff so I'm so
happy that you've been doing it the
shows really funny check it out and yes
please go support that shows a lot of
fun fact-checking today as always mr.
dan Moreau
hi I hope people can hear me this is I'm
gonna wear a little torn off face and
tech issues I can't your don't give
credit to to JT and everyone they've
been working very hard if you're not
seeing it on screen right now it's
broken
so we're that's what I'm doing this
weird thing there's a headphone thing
but yes I'm happy to be
here I'm getting ready for this fight
which is going to be great then one next
week before I'd reduce our fans there's
something I got to do right away in the
show okay next week you're putting the
belton won the belt is on the line
you're going up against Pat Carlson
themselves mr. Mike Carl Hanna Tague
Botanica guess what man what we put
together an awesome promo should we cut
a promo yeah let's hike this fight up I
will no I want to I would you really
haven't seen it all right look it yeah
cue the clip right order versus chaos
the Henry Cavill Superman is a
cold-blooded killer logic vs NRG Han
Solo's kids became Jedi's Indiana
Jones's kid became Shia LaBeouf reason
vs. vote tanika's he helps et create a
spaceship and they grow it out of a
turnip dan Moreau versus Mike Carlson
then still the return champion known as
Sigma del throne yet the belt is on the
line
live on YouTube that's right anyone can
watch Thursday July 13 4 p.m. Pacific be
there no excuses what Wow the live
championship battle is going to be live
on you dive or yes Pacific next Thursday
the world for the world to see the whole
world can come it's just behind the
paywall this is everybody can tune in
for p.m. live next week can set your
series or your Alexa is all your stuff
make sure you set your alerts because
this show is going to be insane I'm so
excited Danny nervous no all right well
you better because I might leave this
show we're going to try something new I
don't any other one judging this one oh
really oh it's live on YouTube that's
probably not a bad idea
not a lot of surprises in store live on
YouTube you are not going to miss this
one so I may implore you all set for
real so your reminders 4 p.m. Pacific
Standard next Thursday live on our
platforms YouTube come support and watch
it's going to be a blast and I'm so
excited see what happens there it's
going to be crazy it's going to be fun
hi guys in the couch we got Tom's and
vino and Devon Taylor welcome guys
I expect to value view whereas one week
off almost almost but no this is gonna
be a great show oh yeah and at the time
I've been watching your ear between you
came where'd you come from again you
came from oh wow you're making a full
trip out of it yeah yeah excited man
welcome to LA I'm excited and Devon that
was good to see you I'm this is gonna be
a lot of fun you both are gonna have to
help me today on the show you download
all right we're good share that might
will we'll make we'll make sure it works
awesome thank you guys for coming love
love your support guys if you may have
read we're going to be going down to San
Diego Comic Con for our official panel
and screen Dougie's news will be down
there covering everything as well but
we're going to be at the House of Blues
on July 22nd that's Saturday we're
taking over the House of Blues for
screen junkies central we're doing a
one-night mega event all of us will be
there and some surprise celebrity guests
that we can't announce yet but we'll be
announcing soon it's very exciting so I
want to make sure you guys all know that
we actually had tickets available we
were going to still offer it but we sold
out in a day even without the celebrity
so it's blown our minds thank you guys
for supporting it all but there's still
a waiting list you can go some up for it
and we're doing a contest sorry I'm
making sure I have well maybe cuz
there's a lot of words here so we have
some special tickets available I'd say
but we're working more at to add more
tickets to the event so go to screen
duckies comets to get on the wait list
plus you can RSVP for the party we want
to see everyone there we have another
crazy party last year were you at the
party last year you were right
he didn't say in the inflatable dinosaur
and on the booze I was very drunk but
you'll be able to meet all the screen
duckies they're in San Diego so RSVP and
come party with us and if we don't
forget about our fans non San Diego if
you don't have hotel travel well here's
your chance one lucky fan and a friend
will win a trip to San Diego and VIP
access of stream Bucky Central that's
right we are giving away a trip and
hotels to come join us so go to screen
degrees comm / SJ central to sign up so
thanks to the new Samsung Chromebook
plus for helping us make this possible
Dan you're using how awesome I have it I
got it and got a fact machine to so say
it I and Maker 2002 that you can flip it
around and stuff on anything I want was
it stand out anything I love it from
book plus thank you so much for
sponsoring this and first
central and all the stuff they've been
helping us with it's wonderful so I'm
saying let's get the show going shall we
yeah
time
[Music]
dr. Mike
oh yeah I love that montage look at
great guys so good love - watch every
second of it the monitors I'm totally
throwing me all right I want to see I
really see everything I can't see it
alright let's go to red one this one
comes in from Brian acquire at Brian man
for now he wants to know what is the
best spider-man performance this is
pretty easy there are three basically
main spider-man that have played so far
yeah and we have certain ones TV yeah
with movies movie Louie three movies
Spider Men that we all know and love
and the three of you of each picked one
so let's see who he picked Alicia who
you pickin first who gave the best
spider-man performance well I'm going
with it joins us from the heart a very
heartfelt performance and that is Andrew
Garfield in the amazing spider-man and
the amazing spider-man 2 he really had
the passion you know he was such a huge
fan of the spider-man comics and we
learnt this from when you were talking
about how he picked business okay so
when he auditioned for the role of
spider-man he turned up with a photo of
himself at four years old dressed up as
spider-man and then during the press
junket you know he cried in interviews
when he talked about putting on the suit
for the first time and that passion for
the role and the the comic book is
really infused into the character he
also had of course amazing chemistry
with Emma Stone and that is one of the
the biggest parts of spider-man to me is
his relationships with his family and
his love interest and their relationship
just sizzled off the screen also I
thought he really put his all into the
films and he was stuck with not the best
group he had to deal with some pretty
junky dialogue written by those guys
behind transformers he had to deal with
some ridiculous over-the-top villains
but he was the best part of those movies
and because he put his heart and soul
into it and he gave a great performance
despite everything he had to go up
against despite not having the might of
Marvel or being the very first
spider-man I think he gave the best
performance alright good start Tony
comers you're pickin I don't know I'm
just picking the newest incarnation Tom
Holland
who
we have seen in Captain America Civil
War
and coming out today spider-man
homecoming right I got to be clear
because they haven't seen it you can't
use homecoming build its new trailers
and civil wars and we have to pay okay
okay that's fine um I mean the thing is
Tom Holland is actually young so he's
actually the age of the character and
within the 30 minutes that he was in
civil war people praised him being the
best spider-man incarnation ever within
just 30 minutes imagine if I had all of
homecoming Joe saying oh all right we'll
we'll imagine and we'll come back here
more Jenny
I wonder her your second oh um it's hard
to decide but I picked Tobey Maguire I
think he is the best spider-man I love
his vulnerability I think he really made
that character I know he's criticized
sometimes as not being faithful to
comics spider-man but I'm looking at it
as its own performance its own character
within the confines of that movie and I
think as far as selling it in that story
he's extremely empathetic it makes you
more exhilarated to see him when he does
have those powers because you've grown
to love him so much as Peter Parker and
I think if it's between getting in the
perfect spider-man and the perfect Peter
Parker Peter Parker is the heart of it
and that's the best part to focus on and
that's what Toby got right so Toby's the
best and no one will ever be better than
Toby and that's what I'm sticking to
that was the right that's it what you
Toby is the best and no one can protest
really I thought you were gonna say and
I'm not when Miss Miranda decided to
wrap in every movie that he's in alright
now we've heard I've got Garfield from
Elisha Holland from Tony and McGuire for
Jenny fight it out guys why is your why
are the other two nods good okay just
really quickly Andrew Garfield vitamin
yes passionate but as for the four year
old photo thing Tom Holland has a photo
of him dressed as spider-man at four or
six married man woman and child on a
fire
you don't get bonus points for that you
also don't get bonus points for having
chemistry with your real-life girlfriend
this is the least impressive thing you
know there could ever do I think you're
blaming everything that went wrong with
that movie on the writing and everything
else but it's like you know he stuttered
quite a lot that everybody was character
choice which made him really endearing I
mean when he asked Gwen out the first
time I was really really I don't need
the thing is I just I think you're I
mean I'm here and coming into if you
really want but I mean the client for
example I mean he's just smokers yes
coming inside Alicia he is a wet blanket
he doesn't greet the real emotion to the
role like like Andrew Garfield did and
tell me why is a great actor I would
give like I really like doctor even but
you also had the advantage of being the
first to really portray the spider-man
origin scene and for Andrew have to step
into that role and do that again and
pull it off not very long after the
first was you know and people were like
oh is this happening again that was
before reboots became a regular thing
Tom Holland brilliant young actor I love
the impossible was really excited when
he was cast I thought he was great in
Civil War but I just think he has such
an advantage because there is no way
that Marvel is going to let this go
wrong again but they really have
everything at their disposal to help him
in his journey and really empower
Kimbrough to play the character where I
don't think Andrew just was playing
against I'm Tom Holland a then 19 year
old was able to go up against Chris
Evans and Robert Downey jr. and hold his
own as an actor proves better than
Andrew Garfield being the star of the
film a pollen stole the show with 30
minutes already being claimed the best
spider-man within 30 minutes of a movie
that he's like 99 future not even like
probably in the in the top 10 credits of
so without him also in the trailers of
spider-man homecoming we see him as an
amazing Peter Parker which Toby did well
and an amazing spider-man as
uh Andrew Garfield kinda did with the
quips and everything so he's everything
spider-man is he is both Peter Parker
and he's spider-man which the
combination of those two is amazing also
he's really young and he captures the
character better than anyone because
your character and yours both graduated
in the first movie high school and then
or what started college or something
like that um right he was a nice one
when he graduated right yeah and then he
graduated um so I think I think by that
point we don't get to see the the
spider-man that we read about in the
comics and the best performance in
spider-man sure might be its own
separate things like you said about you
know Toby maybe not as faithful but the
fact that spider-man is a comic book
character and that Tom Holland and all
the people in the film can encapsulate
what those comic books are and make the
performance as real and unique and still
fantastic just means he is the best
assurance anyway that like you know
Tommy Maguire Christian dumpster didn't
uh popping that one kiss and I'll slow
down which is pretty ironic more or
dimittam than the other I didn't really
buy their relationship and I will say
it's important and I will say that it's
not a cop-out to have you know your
real-life relationship because yes they
do have chemistry but that it doesn't
always translate to the screen it's a
very different thing and the way these
two played up against each other and I
will defend you stuttering because I
think it really is it's only where you
defend a stockroom
okay charismatic great chili charismatic
I mean sure but another way to say hey I
don't want to okay on my way too cool to
be Peter Parker he's writing that great
board through the hole ended up in our
location I'll say the Parker is a nerdy
kid but my plan is to wish-fulfillment
right this is the whole story that's
deadlier a heart meant it has to be
grounded and then Spiderman is right but
every decayed when I read the comic
books I read it as realizing that I was
a young boy who wasn't the coolest who
didn't look a certain way but could
still be someone you know and that's so
relatable more than say in Andrew
Garfield who looks pretty or a Tobey
Maguire who's like just completely
crying about his love by removing very
pretty
sure
or Tom Howley's ugly is what you're
implying no Tom how it is relatable okay
good
I'm going to read it home only be ugly
helps me liked him a lot more no I have
a lot of issues with particularly Andrew
Garfield spider-man you did say that
it's important for him to have that
relationship with his girlfriend and
with his family I didn't really feel
that Andrew Garfield spider-man had that
family connection why especially with
Uncle Ben which is what important my
party was more after a well Uncle Ben an
entire driving force to be spider-man
you got to have Uncle Ben in there and I
felt like he was just in it they kind of
argued then he immediately died I also
felt like the way he portrayed
nervousness was almost like an offensive
caricature of someone with Asperger's
like scratching his ear like it's very
typical like autistic denial I was just
like I'm so uncomfortable watching this
no so he kind of seemed like an actor
that's never been nervous before playing
someone whose nerve and I definitely
know I can see definitely not portraying
that in any way and he's definitely an
act and a character choice and not very
good she never sinned in real life do
you like a really quaint okay I go to
but and I also say I haven't seen a lot
of time Holland so hard to argue on him
but I will say that it's so fortunate
for him that he had Toby performance to
look at why can't get going and that he
has said the line of the Vengeance I
mean you don't really have oh I can't
probably say that uh damn see it's hard
not being able to mention the movie yeah
it might as well not happen I mean the
thing is the fact that you guys can the
only argument you guys have is saying oh
well it's lucky for him he has everyone
to be a part of you can't knock a single
thing again you can't really say
anything bad about my pick because
there's really nothing bad about my are
there bad things about it sick I mean I
like to performance in civil war I
haven't seen homecoming but it wasn't
like wow amazing it was just like he was
great okay sure I mean but I mean the
reviews for both homecoming and Civil
War on him I mean I have nothing to go
on usually any negatives against Tom
from Civil War
thank you finance Wyatt Toby better last
closing point Vento you see og
spider-man he was so many people's
introduction to the character and he
also kicked started like the entire
superhero film movement so I think Toby
deserves major props for that and he
carried spider-man three he also had
difficult scripts and he gave it his all
every time and I respect him for that
okay Tony final thoughts um
Tobey Maguire wasn't that faithful to
the characters that we know and love and
Tom is way more as well as we didn't we
didn't have to retread any you know
origins story with Tom and anything and
homecoming he's just spider-man and I
think that's amazing
sure we have all the Avengers to help us
but that shouldn't stunt his performance
because him as an actor him as
spider-man it's so amazing and he really
encapsulate the role he feels like he's
spider-man and that's what's so amazing
Alicia I found that Andrew Garfield's
oscar-nominated fireman la Rosa
they each chose that he says an actor
with promise and he really brought
everything he could to that role and it
wasn't his fault
I felt like it was sad when they
announced new spider-man I was like oh I
just wanted to see Andrew Garfield get
the script so he deserved to really show
what he could have done in spider-man
and glow because he had so much to fight
against and he did such a good job and
no debates online about this at all it's
not a unanimous decision i doing colin
it really looked available go so you
know for those reasons and more I say
Andrew Garfield dan yeah is it an
anonymous decision there are there are
lovers of all three on there yes there
are lovers of all three right now it's a
it's pretty close for who's the number
one choice from our fan poll some other
actors that were not mentioned Nicholas
Hammond who's TVs amazing spider-man in
the 1970s the oh - Karen it was the
voice of an animated Spider Man appalled
soul to the sixty spider-man held in
ultimate spider-man the shout outs from
Twitter people wanted this person
recognized Reeve Kearney who was quite
around hurt off the dart and play him
like a Jonas Brother
I went through many hazards to do that
role and then question
excuse me Shinji Shinji Toto my favorite
who was Japanese spider-man which if you
have yeah the United one minor man
there's an Indian one named desi
something that I don't know it is an
instant one it's great yeah those are
both very happy maybe I'm your spider
mimic that were not mentioned but added
to the legacy of the Spider Man and yeah
I had the fan vote but let you know
after you almost clover winning out
between a pretty clean fight really this
was hard for me actually
this was legitimately hard because i
kudos Alicia did feel like you were up
against the ropes a couple times but you
did stronger but I let me take the worst
higher they got you a little bit with
just the fact that the fact that he
stuttered a lot that's that old stuff
you defended that well but then the the
fact that it's like the relationship
worked because it was as real a
girlfriend is sore another interesting
point of that was convenient for him Tom
Holland the cons obviously there we
don't see a lot yet but I was pushing it
sort of see what negatives you guys
could bring even in the stuff you have
seen and both of you really did admit
you liked it but Toby Maguire made some
really interesting points she is the OG
he did have lots of their work with I'd
like also when you took down Alicia
about the Uncle Ben part of what made
this my man that is a valid point he
doesn't really do that very well so you
it's really between Tony and Jenny for
me I want to get the fans involved guys
what do you think those arguments
between between three of them really did
you guys have me any feedback great job
knocking down Andrew Garf
she she brought up he the stammering is
that that's the part I couldn't stand
about Andrew Garfield so I mean having
Jesse out there
toby is my boy like she is like I mean
you can't beat it and I think what
spider-man it's almost like a Batman
situation Peter Parker is just as
important you know and I've really
related to
Toby's every man Peter Parker yeah I
mean I there you gave me a lot there
Tony you did because he did steal the
show and they admitted that they said
he'd liked it but I got a little bit
more of the takedown from Jenny against
and Rios that I really like and I think
he
guys gave equal pros so I got to give
Toby and Jenny the first point yeah well
I'll go there I'll break can we say we
couldn't all choose till Molly and I is
the best exit good on Twitter have
chosen Town Hall and 47% motive in Tom
Holland 36% to avoid resent cigar shop
guys okay I afraid back to homecoming it
might have changed things planned a
little more he is really good at
homecoming but if if I did argue I'll be
his props oh yeah I should have said no
too proud to fight all right rau to that
comes in from file Doron ha they want to
know what's the best scene from any
spider-man since we're here with a
spider-man actor
Alicia loves this what's the best scene
from any real Iron Man movie Tony you're
up first
I'm going with the three more fight so
you'll be good at mad about my choice um
I'm going with spider-man to train
fighting scene with Doctor Octopus where
he's fighting on the train with Alfred
Molina is Doctor Octopus and then stops
the Train with his bare muscles Wow
picking a Toby scene taking a Toby soon
yeah Jenni what's he know about Jane
which ok my scene is a scene in
spider-man 1 when Spiderman goes up
against bone saw McGraw so that's
obviously the best moment in the entire
trilogy the entire rainy trilogy and the
entirety of the spider-man Cinematic
Universe so great to see him fighting a
spider-man the first time wonderful
scene Alicia what are you thinking well
given your previous bullets in this
relationship maybe I have an uphill
battle but genuinely my favorite scene
in any spider-man movie is when Grand
eyes in spite of mental image or a
dementia because it is an emotional part
of the series I mean they build up this
great relationship as I said I really
bought into their chemistry I really
loved seeing them on screen together and
then the way that she falls and it's in
slow motion it's probably the most
artistic scene within the amazing
spider-man 2
and it's a bright spark in that pretty
terrible movie she's falling in slow
motion you think that he's going to
catch her and I just assumed when I
watch it the best time I was going to
catch on my way oh I know like in an
autumn stress that was a gruesome and
seven snaps back and he just catches her
and like slams on the ground my god and
I wanted a crack-up ow
yeah I was a chef's and actually really
emotional about it so that's why I'm
choosing that thing all right
it is a most emotionally intense scene
versus two more fight scenes let's hear
it out guys why better Tony back to you
why is your scene the most iconic and
best spider-man scene attaboy these
three well its iconic because first off
spider-man 2 is arguably the best
spider-man film to date and I think it's
so amazing because we have a fight scene
that really captures what spider-man can
do you know hanging off the edge of a
moving train how strong he is there's a
moment where he like slips through the
tiny sliver of a overhead uh what's it
called walkway and and that's incredible
we see how quick he is how depth and Sam
Raimi is fantastic at creating suspense
like there's that whole moment where he
can't find a dr. octopus and we see that
little claw thing kind of come under the
train and we're all very nervous and
scared and so he creates tension within
a fight scene that's not just like
hitting each other as hard as they can
as well as then creating a moment which
i think is iconic for all superhero
movies now is the the struggle of trying
to do something with an incredible feat
of strength you have that now hangs like
right no I mean great just like because
after that you get the Civil War
helicopter hold with Chris Evans biceps
and I can get some Halle Berry zing oh
is it right what cos he does the same
thing that's a name yeah but it's a
series wasn't her but it's the same
thing right but this is the first one
this is set the trend for everyone else
as opposed to you would think short slow
motion but that's only like like who are
they trying to copy zack snyder's watch
men like falling into it's like it's the
date I mean it seems like any kind of
hobby that scene from what is it the
comedian in Watchmen well I went see if
I chose action scenes and it's like yeah
we're super here I found a I guess I'm
not the market for these kind of action
scenes I always enjoy when I can invest
in a character more emotionally and with
that scene I think it was really
exciting on top of the Train but I was
never for once worried about spider-man
I mean he's any fun anyway to save
people they're not going to let a train
full of people die so I was like oh it
looks cool that's great and then your
scene is fun in terms of it being just a
silly is in the outfit gosh you got a
real me treatment provider or door into
the wrestling scene wait first comeback
fighter and he's dressed in that like
oversized outfit and then he says and
any senator curricula did you get that
from your husband which I don't if you
would say that in film these days and
then they have that product and it's fun
because he like my husband did make up
for it yeah he was just trying to remind
him how embarrassed his husband would be
if you lost the match as like no one
really ever okay now that is the first
time we get to see spider-man actually
like fights in with his powers it's a
great point he doesn't even like throw
those away marker kind of yeah it's a
great moment we could see Peter Parker
coming into his own as a fighter we get
to see my favorite spider-man suit which
is like crappy homemade sock one or you
just like put a sock on his head and a
sweatshirt it's endearing I think it's
also great to see a spider-man that Tom
Holland has is nice Tony Stark costume
and Andrew Garfield inexplicably has
this like movie copy more favor
thanks PGI's fighter Man games that I
guess is made from like stuff you got it
Joann Fabric there something never made
sense to me I love this because it's
like he struggles you get to see it kind
of like it's like a scrappy Spider Man
and it drives home that spider-man is
like the underdog superhero plus its
eggs perfectly into Uncle Ben being
killed by the carjackers because
when he's trying to collect the prize
money he makes that judgment call not to
stop the robber lets him get away and it
gets Uncle Ben so it ties in perfectly
with the story of the movie and it's a
great one 30 died again sense with great
power comes great responsibility
remember that Peter so much yeah okay
but you can't I hit you I'm your client
used Uncle Ben's stuff you're talking
about the bones awesome so that we need
a cage match yeah you can't like take
into consideration welcomes me I just
make a point you did TFS you guys needed
hear it again guys okay so and and as
when dying is like I mean remember be
myself I mean holy CGI sure web document
that people in the audience living here
at hands and grab me nervous reg atomic
I knew it was all coming and also was
like I said and I was like what I mean
it was they decided up welding they knew
it was an iconic scene that they wanted
to include but they were like what if
they're in a clock tower and that didn't
make sense to the clock in the end time
and then also okay most men have an icy
Jess it was set up by the narrative and
she keeps trying to go there and help
Peter and he keeps saying stay behind
stay behind like you'll get hurt and
she's like no I'm a strong female
character I'm going to go with you and
then she died of doing that so the moral
was like yeah you should have stayed at
home black ass know your place lady so I
don't think that and the [ __ ] Chinese
amazing like I loved it I mean only
because I hate Andrew Garfield and I was
happy to see him sad
oh my god didn't matter to happen I
would see not like something personal
going on with miss you tonight made him
for what he did to spider-man days I
don't think I don't think it was that
bad I had within my demand was actually
pretty good as when pathetic person the
second one was kind of like yeah you
have a bunch of villains in it and that
that I just feel like you know even the
moment after she died is I will say him
crying afterwards was not I just kicking
a man while he's down
I don't know sucking your balls which
was like CNN I saw this scene as you
pointed out like there's so many other
scenes that you could have chosen if you
want to talk about spider-man coming
into his powers for the first time but I
can leave I leave us
time but he really doesn't see mother I
can't think of I would rather pick
something like I know it's things like
he was trying enough okay okay I'm
coming for you two in a second
but I would have picked that if I wanted
to see something of him coming to into
his own I would have picked the scene
where he fights off the robbers we're
trying to what like hijack or robbed
imagine not to use his powers for
personal gain because of the lessons he
learned following the bonesaw match
right wait or you could have even like
had a moment where he actually finds the
guy who hurt his uncle better killed his
Uncle Ben and that scene would have been
better than the bones up Oh sounds like
more of a comedic just like funny thing
and movies are great for their comedy
and that's like but but that's but
that's why I like Spiderman to the fight
scene is is the first time we get to see
spider-man truly like it's an amazing
action set piece that we never thought
we were going to get to see with the CGI
of its time it was unprecedented I
remember watching as a kid and saying
this is amazing this is everything I've
ever wished for the also the moment
where he stops the train is short you
know it's been used now a million times
but that was the first time and everyone
always looks to that as inspiration so
how can you can you sacrifice your body
as much as you can for that moment so we
not only get to see Tobey Maguire like I
mean I was like the first time so I
spend every dime in spider-man maybe but
I'm sure there's many legacy for your
mind before like like very specifically
not movie I mean I'm just saying as like
as a superheroes like that's something a
common person can't do alright yeah you
were going to take him down go ahead yo
you want to go yonder what your thoughts
against this way I didn't dislike that
scene but it is like immediately
upstaged by the emotional moment
afterward when his mask comes off and
everybody's like he's only a kid so I
feel like you should have picked that
scene and you picked the leakers to when
they're right up against each other I
think the scene that follows almost
makes you forget all the fight scene
that you just watched so to me the
fighting itself was kind of unremarkable
paled in comparison to the emotional
tone element I feel like we've seen that
there's so many even go back to like I
know silent film serials and so we've
seen so many train scenes of jumping on
and off the train and doing ducking
under things that it was exciting but it
didn't really change the genre in any
way or make anything that was like a
huge inspiration apart from I went over
very watch that scene I was like I
didn't they do that again and I'm coming
from what I've seen with the thing that
ferries I go they're different I have to
watch it using as your final thoughts
any final thoughts Tony yeah I think
this scene with Gwen's death was just
like I think it was it was it was there
was nothing really like I didn't feel
surprised by it at all I knew it was
coming
even if I didn't read it they like
Telegraph the whole entire thing
throughout the whole entire movie so it
wasn't surprising and it was quite
boring and if anything it made me laugh
when it happened because it was just a
it was just like kind of hilarious how
bad they did it and as for bones let's
see I forget your choice I'm just saying
it's not at all I'm not a it's not a
memorable scene I I don't really
remember that happening even though you
remember to check out it sure she didn't
wanna know she watched it all yours you
remember I read the answer I was like
what exactly is their invasion sakuni's
they have car numbers on there selling
their home I googled I know I did any
final thoughts um I think the Glenn
Station moment is a moment that's made
cheap by the fact that it doesn't really
fit with anything that happens before or
after it and the theater I was in that
people actually laughed when they saw
that cheesy CGI web hand reaching for
her very heavy-handed so yeah there were
a lot of Snickers which is not a good
sign and as for the Train theme it would
get seen but is kind of another
spider-man fight he's got a lot of good
fight bonesaw
is the first and he's a great memorable
character people love bonesaw and it
goes bones always ready and that's a
great line
that iconic line great line oh yeah yeah
all right damn yeah dad here just a lot
of other scenes people from Oh first of
all a lot of people asked about the
airport scene from Civil War that's not
a spider-man movie service yeah not
eligible for for inclusion here anything
with JK Simmons a lot of people saying
they loves everything that jenna jameson
some support for the lab seen the Doc
Ock kind of birth scene from spider-man
to the Evil Dead scene from Sam Raimi
Green Goblin forcing a Peter Parker to
choose between Mary Jane and the
civilians from the first spider-man me a
lot of people not about so a lot of
different scenes mainly the consensus
it's not more than a few people say
anything but this scene of course being
the dancing scene for spider in a cello
I almost take the omelet scene with Mary
Jane and Oh a barely shilling worth
train for like six hours to learn how to
flip an omelet a degree I wouldn't do it
like it's under that is cuter nose make
City try and like I was nice with the
characters we get specific area always
frustrated at the bass hall has made
their decision which I will tell you
about sure it's a clear in the fairly
clear winner yeah yeah I'm guessing it's
not bone saw same personal for both ah
yes look I think you wanted battling
effort there Jenny it was you did it's
good I I think we all set me to be
reminded of the scene which was the
problem and that's ultimately which is
because it's a bunch of fake fans know
we are fair I mean you were clearly the
biggest spider-man original fan so I
will give you that but if it came down
between Gwen dying and train fighting it
look I think Alicia gave some while I
you know I got taken my personal pains
that have the laughter which I think you
made good points on it isn't emotionally
investing scene and someone who's not as
welled up in the comics it is sort of
out of nowhere
whoa they killed while the lead
love-interest make ricin and you made a
good point you're never worried about
spider-man next train sequence because
you know no one's going to die so that
was a very good point back to him that
said you did point out Tony it's very it
is full attention even still and the Doc
Ock moments are really great sets the
tone for all those hero shots that we
see later it is probably his most iconic
fight from that trilogy I think is a sea
thing to say so do you go for
emotionally investing or most iconic
bite scene
I think I just heard more criticism
against the Glen deaf so I got to give
Tony the point there don't you get it
they say online then it was a pretty
clear victory online make sure get the
latest numbers here 63 percent now
voting for the spider-man 2 trained by
21 percent voted for Gwen's death
so we shall find diamond confirmed
children and Andrew Garfield was never
coming on the show we met and you know
we go so Larry really nice oh you see
monkeys manager Maria great yeah I'm
gonna keep even a photo feedback about
those movies we had some coach about it
but he said like there's nothing he
could do he tried his hardest yeah no I
don't blame I don't blame him for that
movie no he said I really want the
second one once in the audience and Toby
knew I said the same thing he was like I
only saw a spider-man 3 once and I was
once two minutes yeah they won't make it
his intent a few movies you never know
alright love it alright question 3
alright : brother Stephen Lynch both up
new TV shows out Fargo and when Peaks
are thriving on TV we want to asked what
unlikely film director should create and
direct their own series and obviously
got pitched me sort of what movie is
loosely based on that they would do this
on we're back to our up to you Jenny
you're at first okay director what do
you want to see to a TV series
I picked Tim Burton we've never seen
well I've never seen him work in TV I
didn't research it that thoroughly just
going to put that out there maybe he did
we don't know it's a mystery um and what
movie would be based on all of his
movies all of them it'll be like him by
universe not cinematic fire television
universe obviously can't get Johnny Depp
because he's a film actor he's expensive
and in my perfect world he's been hit by
a bus already so you would have awkward
like look-alike sound-alikes of all of
his roles oh wow and there were also the
main character would be an awkward
character names Jim birdie
and he's obviously a ripoff of Jack
Sparrow and you can feel that Tim Burton
is really upset that he didn't invent
Johnny Depp's most iconic role so that
would be a good candidate because player
yeah it would be like a cheap like
spirit Halloween store version of a Jack
Sparrow costume called chimbure and it
would be like an awkward college guy
that thinks he can do the voice for the
lead of the show she's going drunk and
it's like it's like a detective serial
so you can have your crime of the week
and yeah because all in all the movies
chock Charlie the chocolates down there
on my tractor Frank yeah i'm planet of
the apes they even invite miss
Peregrine's school oh alright so you're
going over there yes all right
oh I love ordinary more it isn't because
inside no it did we show which what are
you thinking I'm thinking Kathryn
Bigelow she's one of the best action
film directors around she's so good at
creating tension at throwing you right
in the middle of a crazy situation and
particularly great with war films and I
love The Hurt Locker I thought that was
really exciting
it showed a different side of the
military that I hadn't thought about too
much particularly the fact that it shows
that war is a drug and that I think is
such an interesting kernel of an idea
that could be spun out into an exciting
television show where she would keep you
on the edge you asleep waiting for the
next episode and it would be a limited
series very high-end production but so
I'll take in place sort of Hurt Locker
style through water wolves an area yeah
cool modern-day wolf yeah yeah Tony what
were you thinking I'm taking Quinn
Tarantino and it will be loosely based
on Reservoir Dogs Quinn Tarantino is a
master filmmaker who has such a huge
audience and he's already directed a
couple of episodes of CSI that's true
and it is true the roulette through
which I could so surprised but he has
not created and direct his own TV series
and I think what better way and to give
this man a large time frame for him to
tell a narrative between all these
characters all-out Reservoir Dogs Pulp
Fiction
inglorious basterds different main
characters and have them all interject
you know season finales are going to be
huge things but his dialogue is always
amazing
directors are always interesting he's
always pushing the envelope his action
is amazing and the way he writes scripts
is just something we've not seen in
television right now which is that um a
you know dark story with like a tiny bit
of a light-hearted touch and fun like
you know jabs and jokes from here and
then I think that's why he would be the
best to do a creative director film is
it just resurrector you said inglorious
but they're all showing up - no I'm just
saying like like the dialogue of his
unlikely a unitary nerd universe no no
just reservoir that so it's like a all
these dinner behind Roger pink mr. Brown
mr. all these guys dead right yes much
better ones there only one someone you
know is is doing the same like crimes as
crime syndicate a la Reservoir Dogs
after hearing their story and we get to
see you know a very Tim Rothman like
character you know interject and be that
you know a guy who's like you know
working for the police but I mean they
like to figure out you know slightly I
am like Fargo has shown it's it's
loosely yes you loosely cuz they're not
based on the movie but got it they date
see mags alright great
let's point it out guys um first thing I
want to touch on is Kathryn Bigelow I
think is incredible and I think you're
right she creates such tension but we
have so many TV shows like that already
you know one show being a show that
they're filming right now called Medal
of Honor about Medal of Honor winners
and there's so many different TV shows
Band of Brothers was a miniseries so
there's so many stories like that
already told and master directors who
can make tension since in TV universe
very soon different though is the idea
of exploring a how war can be really
addictive to people because that is so
fascinating a little touch of an idea in
Hurt Locker where you think that looks
like the worst job of all to dismantle
bombs and why would you want to go back
once you get home and I think exploring
that in terms of modern-day war and the
stuff that was going on right now and
the the pool people feel to go back and
keep fighting I think that could be
really interesting I agree but I think
the movie was the best way to tell
that's
with one person I don't feel like you
can continually make that story four
episodes long oh gotta go I get another
bone damn it oh man I gotta go Tom I
supposed to read long gone and I was
laying back showing you how a Sorkin and
characters can evolve from a good
character to a huge that was such a
great story because it was so
self-contained because it wasn't about
the heist itself it was about the
characters so the most interesting thing
and either never actually see the heist
is the aftermath of the heist and the
fact that it took place within such a
limited time line is what makes that
movie really exciting that there is a
connection there is an ending short that
to have it continued for episodes is
just a blood get more difficult but the
views and we based on it's not going to
be about Van hise also Quint Ernst you
know has a wonderful filmography that we
can pull from and see inglorious
basterds how short it is hopefully when
I'll show it as I say always for paid
himself so I won't want to say the same
thing from him I want to say something
exactly he doesn't repeat himself so he
would be creating new episodes all the
time but then the Tin Man but how many
would you even want my best job I was in
um nightmare more and more shows like an
existential looking up what's another
show about okay well I'm Jim birdie is
he's sitting in his pirate office and
Jim there from the office - no I'm God
from big fish walks in and says I need
you to help me my son has been kidnapped
my adult son that I'm estranged from so
he gets up that family conflict right a
friend he's estranged from his son
you're already invested and he goes the
Jack Sparrow character says I know where
they've taken him and they've taken him
to Wonderland to CGI Wonderland so they
go there obviously it's on a TV budget
so it's a lot it's like flash animated
when they get too long around it kind of
looks like a Saturday morning cartoon
show but only a series it can appeal to
any age demographic and its biggest
virtue is you can merchandize it you
guys have shows like oh maybe some fans
would buy like a pop figurine or so
thing but this one we can sell t-shirts
and hats and place that Funko pops by
the thousands and make it sell maybe one
or two is their task because Funko
Hasselblad like virus anywhere enemies
well he can't get the licensing for
obviously there's a Disney gesture but
he's just always felt really bothered
that he didn't own Jack Sparrow because
that's Johnny Depp's most iconic
character Tim Burton right so weird I
dunno she'll go like I know her
characters they have the going to stop
the bomb and do it my they're creating
heist after heist or doing different
crime syndicate stuff so after they find
the subtle ok picture my kind of like
epic movie but a TV show and it's out of
my eyes you mean insane online is so
much because so the clown is likely
dolly and Burton character just sounds
like a pair of nano epic movie well
you're saying you when you watch it and
absolutely not even more to carry on no
you ain't even watch one episode not at
all cuz we're gonna roll a clip right
now
no way TV's broken but it's a very
valuable property
oh they're cute alright alright well
we've heard of Tim Burton universe what
do you think Jenny about these other two
the cat Hurt Locker and reservoir guy I
think that one just sounds like a downer
I'm dating yeah those tweens are not
going to be watching The Hurt Locker
series they'll be really hard to move
those Hot Topic
Diamond Collection Hurt Locker tie-ins
um and yours I feel like would have he's
so fond of like killing his characters
and fantastical ways I feel like it
wouldn't sustain itself for very long
whereas Kimber is never going to run out
of character I'll just I'll just name
one TV show that does that Game of
Thrones and look it out they're gone
somebody killed that many that
frequently they'll kill and right but I
mean this is a TV show I think Quinn
Tarantino knows to pace himself no he
doesn't
also as a matter I'm feeling it
interesting and he there was six of them
and they all died within what an hour
and a half so but this is really just
absolutely based on where it'll grow
into like a crime syndicate it won't be
just this one heist this one little
thing it'll be you know
they how they got together who their
stories are what their families like and
we get to like evolve on these
characters as opposed to just you know
seeing them for the limited time we have
some fun suggestions from our Twitter
followers watching live at random
reviewer says I'd like to see the actual
Steve Zissou series done by Wes Anderson
NOLA Dean Shane Black should write and
direct a nice guy's Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
shared universe TV show Robert Moore at
style around 55 denis villeneuve doing a
sci-fi drama maybe with a lost feel Jack
Mayer take all these Harry Potter
prequels off a movie slates have david
yates make an anthology series out of
these ideas and angelou CEO says how
about John Carney asynch Street Fame
doing a show about musicians I know we
all love music
Tarantino did indeed direct in 2005
grave danger part 1 and 2 for CSI also
directed an episode of ER and like that
I realized I think um yeah I don't know
we did it oh yeah yeah so other than
that clean round they have the the fan
poll is fairly definitive but I will
share that actually major well you had
me till you mentioned epic movie and
then that was sadly I'm not ruined
afraid that did ruin it for me so really
I want to watch but I enjoyed the
creativity the flash animation all this
Funko pop really did sound like a
nightmare they deserved a [ __ ] although
Johnny Depp Willy Wonka Inc so then it
came down between Alisha and Tony I just
think Alicia was able to knock yours
down a little harder even Jenny hit you
a little bit and the fact that Tarantino
would never want to repeat himself and
the limited timing of the heist and not
see nice is what made that exciting I
think you know you it's not going to be
just about bombs I'm imagining you're
talking about modern war seeing Kathryn
Bigelow tell us a longer story in that
in the universe sounds definitely
interesting Alicia gets the point
hi I'm Jesse mixing reservoir dogs' 33
percent voted for Quentin Tarantino 26
percent Tim Burton and 21 percent oh
you're already there you go yeah well we
definitely the best show but yeah you
you know your audience there Tony all
right here we go question four in honor
of the bad mom
Christmas trailer which I'm pretty
genius idea I have to give them thanks
no the first one work it was like a
niche thing ever that's what I think
that was a smart follow-up for their
audience to like make one up to
Christmas crasher really really well for
that if you look at the Horrible Bosses
2 did you ever go - no and I wasn't
saying that bad mom was good for his
demo I think this is a brilliant demo it
was definitely funny parts of it mom
this so in honor of this Christmas team
we want to ask what movie should make a
holiday themed sequel let's get it going
before the holidays come back Leigh
Shore back to you what movie franchise
or movie do you want to make the holiday
sequel for well in a similar vein to bed
mom's but one of my favorite comedies is
bridesmaids because not only was it
funny hilarious great selection of women
but also it told some truths about
female relationships and our friendships
and also that kind of very relatable
feeling that you get when your friend
tells you that they're getting married
and you're like I'm happy for you but I
haven't got my life together yet and
that is something that exactly that I
feel around Christmastime because
Christmas to me is the time when you go
over to your friend's place and there's
it brings up a lot of feelings it brings
up a lot of issues about family about
relationships and I think it could be
really relatable if any Christian week's
character still hadn't quite got her
[ __ ] together and sorry and she hung and
she still was kind of feeling like beard
the adults at the kids table and she
goes to Helens place and it's all
seemingly perfect on the surface and and
she's wondering you know whether she
should have grown up by now and I think
that Paul Feig did such a great job of
the first one I'd love to see more from
him with these characters cool
bridesmaids Christmas Story holiday
story Toni what are you picking I'm
going with that Richard Linklater's
Dazed and Confused Christmas I think
that movie is the perfect movie to make
a sequel to we've already seen with
everybody wants them that it is a
possible thing to to do that narrative
type stuff a thing again so I would love
to see and revisit these characters you
know coming home for Christmas talking
about their stories seeing old friends
because that's something everyone goes
through and I think that would be such a
wonderful tale and Dazed and Confused
was such a perfect narrative on how you
know high schoolers act from freshman to
senior and we get to see you know maybe
the youngest kid I can't remember with
the older sister he's right about to
graduate college his sister's coming
back from you know he's right he's about
to graduate high school and his sister's
coming back from college we see the
family dynamics between everyone you
know the stories and everything and
that's what made people fall in love
with a Dazed and Confused
was seeing all these different
narratives and I think you could do that
easily and find a different wonderful
story at Christmas time with Dazed and
Confused all right Jenny all right -
Jurassic world I think it's another
logical choice it would obviously be
called Jurassic winter wonderland and
the setup for this is that climate
climate change is upon us
so Isla Nublar is now covered with snow
everyone assumes that's killed the
dinosaurs because they're really cold
blooded they're like oh they're all dead
but they're not they're just dormant so
we've seen all those cool like hills and
mountains and stuff like in the in the
distance of Isla Nublar so they've taken
it over as a ski resort and it's got
like all these snowy slopes so people
are now going there to ski and little do
we know that in the basements of one of
the ski lodges we still have some Dino
eggs waiting to hatch when they switch
the generators on to have all the people
come in for vacations and well heat some
up wakes up the dinosaurs these
dinosaurs can't live long in the snow so
they got to go into the cabins they're
seeking out the warmth but there are
tourists in all of those and it's like a
Santa's Village situation it's called
winter wonderland obviously they don't
mention that there used to be Jurassic
Park there it's not good PR how long ago
is this from Jurassic world it's about
30 years later so literally everyone's
forgotten they have no idea like they
make memes about it like it's not a
fresh wound anymore all those people
that died oh yeah what what question mmm
yes all you can run through the road is
where we went next
all right baby well you're more I want
to watch you more it's like a trailer
all right got it yeah dinosaurs are
getting in the cabins are they eating
the pizzas all right yeah all right you
sure I am a gingerbread man all right
find out guys I'm just saying like how
do they not realize the dinosaur eggs
are there I'm like writing an honest
trailer for this already okay I realize
they're covered with tart hey Stan
how does someone building a ski resort
not open up ugh they think it's a
furniture you still wanna use everything
in a survey dur you don't realize it's
going away what's in your way like em I
like the weather Bible and knows that
that stuff healthier now whenever most
down in those thirty years later no
one's there telling your cleaning crew
like oh my god that were here so I'm
about like Jurassic world they don't
want to learn something it's like why do
you keep going back to this island you
should generally know they're going to
go back in Jurassic world to they can't
happen I really know okay there you go
ridiculous what is the point I was it
called an Jurassic world Kingdom [ __ ] he
wants King Holland Kingdom what that
sounds like a bad Michael Bay
transformer movie
Jenny didn't far off Jurassic winter
wonderland okay look they didn't want
the people that are working there to
know about the dinosaurs you of course
coconut wintertime it's Santa's Village
yeah do this and magic Roberto you're
holding back up a la siroque ER with a
big novelty candy cane that sounds like
a ridiculous movie that everyone would
hate on including myself but everyone
would see it sounds like a great matter
so Jamie built an actual I would see it
five times in theatre because I just of
course it's the range I know a lot of
playsets again describe everything under
the tree is going to be Jurassic winter
wonderland action said there was a thing
that yeah there's Santa Santa is like we
have we get to see a cool fight with him
like dinosaur dr. Price's himself from
right over here but he's like a
I might help you here we're having a
John Goodman he's like I'll hold them
off run kid
I need like Santa's coming to town so
ridiculous name I know they present a
tradition Kendra - oh yeah absolutely
Jenny's getting some celebrity I didn't
go to Africa Sonia we was here back so
funny well I love Dazed and Confused but
what I would prefer to see is more of a
high school reunion with them like a
reason to have all the characters back
in the one spot and reminiscing because
I feel like Christmastime unless you
said it there must be some kind of
reason why they suddenly haven't seen
each other in so long and why they're
reuniting at this point rather than
right um they're all afraid Christmas
because it feels like that something
that worked and everywhere they go back
home to their Shores they surely would
have seen each other before then right
exactly but some don't go home for the
holidays are all split out and why they
okay no there's no special reason but
that was so great about Dazed and
Confused was there any special reason no
there were just high school kids doing
what I think at high school right
exactly and and suddenly they all just
came back there doesn't need to be an
explanation of a reason if she can have
John Goodman accustomed with occasion
mine doesn't need a raise the game for
all these years we come back every Union
together is already been done in 10
years and American Pie I mean sure I
don't want to say it Daisy to do sequel
because I think it was so graphic by
itself and right everybody wants some is
a great spiritual seeker I think doing
dub sequel that was smart
everybody wants them to do it that way
rather than to bring the cash right but
a holiday special would make sense it
would make more sense than just doing a
sequel to the movie because it's like it
is a Christmas themed movie yet we don't
have to have any Christmas things or or
you know talking about Santa it's just
about these kids reuniting and that and
anyone out seeing what they do and that
was so great about the first one is we
get to relive that make with an
animation alright is this you know a
you've got the shame black you're
bringing out there the loneliness and
and how it makes you feel at Christmas
right and that's what we can touch upon
there
I'm sure Richard Linklater would do
something with you know who's in a
relationship what past relationship you
haven't seen in a while
all those little nuance things that
every single character feels you know
he'll add it to his story just like he
did in Dazed & Confused you know you
have the stoner what was he up to
does Matthew McConaughey saying all
right all right all right once again you
know talking about how he's still
sleeping with high school girls because
they stay the same
hey creepy as opposed to like bridesmaid
is I think they wrapped that out so
beautifully that she like found her guy
you know that like retreading that and I
think was so great about that is is
seeing these females in that wedding
atmosphere I don't know what you could
add to it without being like a
ridiculous movie and not nearly as good
as the first well adding Christmas to it
for every I went with Christmas was
particularly because you know weddings
and holidays are these moments that
really bring up feelings for you so
that's when you can really touching some
relatable stuff and look at different
family dynamics different relationships
different friendships and that those are
the moments that I really want but
you'll get that all in days and compare
because that's what it was a movie was a
for debridement and capsular
window.google I feel like I don't want
to know where those characters ended up
because I just like to have them in my
mind is always being forever young I
don't want to see this as Matthew
McConaughey Librium video and I don't
want to see what happened to Kristen
Wiig I don't want to see her sad she had
that happy ending in the end so I'm
going to do that and no I think we
should help on 9/8 Jurassic world logo
I've already said how shareable in a
movie that would be further back
ideological blog that I would never want
to see that movie and and we're happy
hearts with flawless logic through and
through and I said that but that was the
first time you are you doing via the the
first time originality this is what we
tried a different class also like you
can imagine so we've been getting
consistent Jurassic Park movies and
those questions still come up never
addressing the world it's always
different sort of me I want dinos
tourists Alice Crimmins all right they
are paid letters that's my question they
would know he's taking that test you're
lucky
Garvin all right and we'll win this for
San what am I saying over there anything
a lot of suggestions from our viewers at
home
Jessi Castro says a nod to one of Tony's
movies it would never happened but
Christmas at the grand Budapest hotel
absolutely side-splitting should be
right over
Jenna's Metrodome printe I would rather
Joe Christmas yeah so Christmas would be
great Rosa
how about inception one of Cobbs kids
tries to accept him to get what they
want for christmas Wilson suggested Mad
Max a wasteland Wonderland I think that
again and Lee Anne summer says Seth
Rogen and Zac Efron and a
christmas-themed what in the UK and I
think overseas it's called bad neighbors
over just called neighbors neighbors
movie a christmas-themed neighbors movie
Oh that'd probably be not probably have
done better than the other Christmas
when he did
maybe so yeah before I thank you very
well it's just so it's an okay movie
with a brilliant performance from
Michael Shannon in it what he's great
right well all right this is tough is it
yeah well we should dig say roast in
arena their website I did there was a
music video that went around that a
butch Walker made where they brought
Matthew McConaughey back it's a good
check it out for life or something
that's called do it feels right you
should look anyway I was 20 million you
get to see that character come back in a
way yeah okay cool I think it's called
synthesizers is what's come anyway all
right tangent but they we did seem come
back and it was kind of fun but
regardless of that personal preferences
side you did get a point like the
probably the high school reading will be
the better use of them which I did like
so it ultimately came down for
bridesmaids and surprise like Jurassic
Park to so it was really silly
all these stupid holiday sequels what's
the point of them on there when you have
John Goodman Santa Claus with the candy
cane hits fighting off a t-rex I think
you were happening a little bit I've got
a house can we go serious here with
bridesmaids or we go silly with Jurassic
Park winter one day I love horror movies
that happen on Christmas by foreign
action movies and combos from st. Louis
oh my represent there so I'm always good
with Santa Claus Wow Tom do you think
well if if I were green lighting a movie
Alicia's hands down but I kind of want
to see what happens there that's tough
did we go for the green light or what we
want to see Dan I know does not want to
see it not so much no ah that was WOW
Alicia there you go yeah I was about to
go but there you just gave Jane the
funny point Wow right mix you will never
happen alright well there is a sequel so
like what do I care what life's about
what did they say on my damn Jurassic
world actually right now is winning 39
over bridesmaid 36 right there was
nothing fun about it even hearing I know
I know I was nobody's are stupid
sidelines movies listen we've make it
really cool I had you though sand off
Dana so adjustable so Dan said which one
we do here like I'm serious
which one which one of you can i when I
was in a quandary because they didn't
want to see any of them III don't know
my name is knowing that you're a
sequinned your Wonderland existed now
even though they should be admitting
that they're crappy I mean if it kills
the franchise I guess in a way yeah I
just killed the franchise everybody and
we got to see John Goodman with a blank
expect cause when the candy came back up
you're out the Raptor yeah yeah alright
set aside someone make that chip please
or that's about that artwork set man
alright question five here we go so
jenny is now in the lead you've made it
your final penny
round good luck so it's between Tony and
Alicia who's going to join you and let's
see this is it this is a big question
let's say you know you've finally met
the one
alright the one you love one you want to
be with whatever it is when he or she
tells you this is their favorite movie
what is the movie you want to hear when
you know you found the one the older
movies to sort of base your relationship
and a future with someone because you've
liked this movie Oh
Bendel's it yeah Tony what movie do you
want us here the what movie do you want
this person to say as their favorite
movie Empire Strikes Back
Star Wars let's go around here on the
movies yes alright Jay spider-man 2002
okay and Alicia police guys called me
pretentious but Emily comely all right Q
the trick question now I'm kidding
oh oh really open for it out of an
agreement
alright tell us why why is that why is
it most important for you to meet you
why is this movie so important that
would deem the person the one for you
guys go ahead would you like to go first
so don't know or well your friends by
open up s right okay I can um well Star
Wars Empire Strikes Back is not only
just a brilliant film but it also is
like a nerdy film and I feel like that
culture is being accepted now so much
that when you find that when she tells
you she likes this movie you know she's
going to be wanting to watch these
movies you know time and time again
they're classic movies you can have fun
it's a wonderful movie and it is the
best of the series so she has great
taste
um and you know Star Wars is such a huge
thing that it's like you know this is a
movie that we can watch you know on
Christmas at anytime and we can you know
bond over where the movies go where the
merchandising goes I can ask her what's
her lightsaber of choice you know is
sheis it and it great it expands to this
whole universe that we can share
together alright
magenta spider-man okay well there's the
reason I'm wearing all these spider-man
layers even though it's like $8,000 you
later like sweating no it's not for you
absolutely not
I'm gonna just girls fire is not only my
favorite dish for a movie it is my
favorite movie I've seen in a million
times and everyone know I absolutely
feel that way oh the Sam Raimi first
spider-man yeah more than Star Wars yeah
I said it I've said it but now I know
like every line from that movie I love
how campy it is I love how seriously it
takes itself despite how campy it is got
some great dialogue great performances
so if somebody like appreciates that one
then I appreciate them alright well here
more Alicia well I think Emily gets
unfairly tied with two quirky kind of
brush but it is such a sweet movie it's
got a great heart to it if if a guy told
me that this was his favorite movie I
would melt into a puddle on the floor
just like she does in the film because
it's a movie that I watched time and
time again over and over and over and
plus it would indicate to me that he is
interested in checking out foreign films
that he's interested maybe in French
cinema that he's interested in just
movies that are outside of the box and
also that he has a really romantic sweet
side to him so not only could we watch
it together but it does open up more
possibilities for the kinds of films
that we could watch together because
that's what I do is I sit at home and
watch foreign film so for me to find
someone who says that a would be extra
special and I think that's a thing like
I think for both of these choices it's
like great you're like movies but Emily
it would be like wow you like
specifically that movie then that shows
to me that you are really interested in
the kinds of things that I'm interested
it's the Fassler question I love our
answers because they're all personal
choices but a healthy are why why why
help me why you think this one really
does for anybody out there to sort of
say this is the one you want your one to
knit to like coming well I think you
know only is a good film and it's a
fantastic film but I think that's more
geared towards you as opposed to both
her and I choice are geared towards what
most hey I most people would want you
know like you know what I mean there's
partners okay like there's a lot of
people who Emily's not their favorite
but and a lot of people who enjoy sight
is out of the one right but that's the
one for you why does the warning and
March are the possibility that not more
I people is this Star Wars Celebration
you can find a million ones there that's
go no I really I was there anyway when
I've so many friends we went right home
and he loved that maybe because be
honored that you did do that and all
their favorite shrimp yeah we did it up
to address to disclose me and they also
have a point and II don't know but I
doesn't signify the was like whoa the
soulmate one I mean I get it that you
don't learn anything that you love and
community for the possibility of the one
as opposed to yours it's like for me I'm
thinking about it for the general world
you know I'm nothing a bit for myself on
it they have to pick my movie no it is a
personal choice that's how you join
there's more people in common with mine
that would choose yours is mine well
your I would say all three T's of
popular movies but yes empires the most
popular movies that we're trying to say
yes that more people would have if they
were answering this question gotta
answer the same that a good thing do you
want your wife to like the most popular
movie well I mean it's not population
it's my point my point here was that
more people if you ask them this
question they would probably answer with
my answer as a path to omelet or with a
higher success rate gotta so so I don't
know I like the side margin why is the
vibe so why do you want one with a lower
success rate why is that better that's
I'm done Sean O'Casey I career so one in
particular it's so romantic to think of
an idea of a soul mate that there is
possibly one person out there that you
could share your life with Jake
Gyllenhaal and you know I think if you
can't doubling record I think you know
if you see if someone turned around and
it seems like a scene from a movie you
know if someone turned around said that
was their favorite movie would be like
oh my gosh yeah you're the special one
and so I just think it's much more
special when you choose a film that
wouldn't be everybody's favorite film uh
then
films that of
a popular rule you have a high success
rate of finding us I mean give me a
little bit of Elias spider-man why is
that the one that's going to narrow
personal choices beyond that why do you
think of making sense of humor is so
important I think that one kind of
indicates someone sense of humor I would
assume that people like the spider-man
Raimi trilogy you have a level of self
self deprecation that I like and I think
a lot of people that like the rainy
movies take spider-man 2 which in my
opinion was not as good as the first one
so so it's a pain I get the higher
specificity there even room Eyre
specifically give me wider is the most
specific why I think it's more because
it indicates what they could possibly
you know be open to I mean I've dated
people that haven't been interested in
seeing anything other than you know
what's under the cinema and what is that
the mainstream American movies and
basically three percent I can't yet it's
mating Safari so then why in strange
film so yeah what one of one it depends
on what you're saying like you people
would say breathless or you know but who
loves me
yeah and so it's like you know but for
me for that indicates not only that
they're interested in foreign film but
also they have this romantic side which
is important to me to have someone with
us alright this is a hard one to judge
but I last last point I'm going to make
if you couldn't pick your own which of
these other two would you want your
person to say I couldn't pick Tommy's
getting between Empire Strikes Back or
spider-man Harket Johanna like which one
do you want to like I would probably say
Empire Strikes Back because I think it
is a it's a better sell better film
Aladdin iconic you want your your Jake
Gyllenhaal whoever your dick go out
there don't you want to be like my
Romilly or spider-man I'm going
spider-man um well I mean I mean that's
more of just a personal choice for me
but also I just think it's like you know
that's a movie that I can I can engage
with I'm a bit of a nerd and for that to
be nerdy okay yeah yeah the fact that
that's accepted it's great you know what
I must pick Hall is Toby McGuire but I
would want to thank you
take to enjoy Star Wars okay yeah all
right all right that didn't help me too
much but I was curious all right hai-yah
mess no I think that there is a funny
picture mother look Anna Devane Adams
Ames we're nick said after meets The
Godfather shows their patient movie
viewer and like action and drama and
enjoyed deep stories and looking at the
viewer poll I think it either supports
or undercuts one of these arguments what
is a judge so ya know what if she was
rewarded for exactly but the truth a
connective mode actually well so I was
trying to go broader and you guys help
me with the broader and I do think the
specific specificity to do that right
specificity help yeah I think Tony you
got lost a little bit for me of just
like it was so personal but you picked
the most popular movie which I think
sort of yeah I see we've staying there
but then it's like I liked their
arguments if you want to go even more
niche to sort of make sure they really
have those connection with you because
everyone likes Empire um but so that's
where I think based on these arguments
whether it's not my personal choice I'm
Lee and spider-man gave me weird reason
spider-man's an odd choice but you
explained why very well because if they
like spider-man 1 then it but most
people experiment to better does the
higher dire rate the sense of humor self
to fruition and then yes Alicia
definitely outside the box a little bit
of the choice it is definitely more of
the mainstream arm fillory but it's the
more romantic side so i'm tour between
cheese i want to go to the fans tom it
guys give me some plots here anything
you heard there that helps why your
argument well I think Alicia had the
best point against Tony and just had
knocked him down for the whole Empire
Strikes Back doesn't narrow it down
Jenny made a really good point about the
people who like spider-man 1 over
spider-man 2 really does kind of narrow
things down but Alicia made a lot of
good points that it's kind of I'm not
normal for someone's favorite movie to
be Amelie so that really does narrow
things down so I think she made a better
arguments for why they would be Devon
quick thought yeah I mean
you definitely want to go a little bit
more specific you know as much as I'd
love to argue the Spidey trilogy with
the one I love I want somebody that
really understands me like nightmares my
favor and I want somebody likes weird
stuff to Dan and Ewan after this to me I
recorded as I said I don't know why I
have a hard for people to vote on a
personal question I do think it was a
personal question and I would also
aiesec side with Alicia she gave for me
the most reasons for her specifically
wise that would be the one so I think I
would I would say that's where I was
leaning you guys solidified it for me
Alicia gets the final point I need to
meet you Jenny and our final two Tony
though hey you don't need a win you're
in a hit movie that's your the one who
really wins today everyone goes see home
coming up they're all going to see
homecoming I mean I not even plug it
dude hey Holly my buddy
yeah yeah a lot Marcia hey when I will
plug it in it's very great and Tony
stick around because now you're going to
help judge this here I know these two
here we go both of the speed round
Alicia Jenni you know how this works
you'll get 20 seconds and you'll get 10
seconds for your rebuttals you got it
think quick if you both say the same
answer it's whoever said it first no
Jesus man you have to pick another one
if you said a second any questions
before you get here the speed round
music let's do this alright this is a
broad question okay what is the best
movie to watch when you're tired and
know you won't make it to the end
normally remember me
oh the Robert Pattinson moving yeah okay
sorry okay when you sigh it and you know
happen when you know you're not going to
be able to later and talk about Pacific
yes it's personal yeah there's a letter
carefully listening um yeah I'm gonna go
with a peasant choice again and say
Fight Club Fight Club Oh interesting
okay the twist there David ready here we
go 20 seconds begin really begin
speaking hi Jenni remember me is a
pretty by-the-numbers romance kind of
Nicholas Sparks II and then it ends with
Robert Pattinson dying via 911 in the
Twin Towers so I think that anybody
who's into that
Rose movie is not going to want to stick
around for the last five ten minutes so
I think that one would be vastly
improved by not having an ending on
there so he just stays alive yeah okay
times up Alisha twenty seconds
when I'm tired and I know I'm not going
to make it to the end of the movie I
want to put on a film that I know about
the film that I've seen time and time
again a film that feels very comforting
to me and that is my club which I know
is a weird choice to say it's comforting
but it really is to me I love David
Fincher I love his movies everybody
knows that choice though it's not like
you're going to wait to the end and be
like what happened it's one of those
movies that you can just put on and no
matter we jump in the story you'll
always get it ten seconds final go ahead
Johnny even if you know the ending twist
I think seeing it play out is like the
most satisfying part of the movie so
cutting it off would ruin it a little
for me okay maybe we should ten seconds
I have no idea what remember me is I've
never been seen it and I I think that it
doesn't sound very interesting so I'd
rather soily I'd rather put a film on
that I've seen before if I'm not going
to pay alright Robert Pattinson the girl
from lost right with China mo never
leave me Emily teary yes that's all I
know I can picture the poster all right
that was that time is up a Tony based on
those arguments are you going to go
totally say okay well yeah well I mean
she she touched the bond like the twist
we already know and then she hit upon it
slightly but it made sense to me that
it's like you've already and watching it
again you know the twist you can see
little more details which you can then
see even though you since you already
know the twist is happening and it's
going to come as opposed to this I
didn't really hear much about oh I did
well I'll say I did I was going with
James and I thought she didn't give me a
book I don't want to see him dying nine
eleven that's so super depressing let's
live in the romance and then yeah I
thought there was a good point there
plus I had to twist this at its fighing
even though I know and I wanted to see
it again so I was leaning crusceni but
let's see what you guys think on the
couch one it's yeah quickly it was a
crafty fight by his Jenny but Iago is
play shows at last
no the ones who seen a million times you
agree yeah I think Alicia made the
better argument for why it's kind of the
comfort watch for and I'm gonna brought
her asleep I guess sadly enough I agreed
with it all so I really all I got from
Jenni was just what happened at the end
of remember me and I want to mix Italy
this stronger I think it was a bit of
were compelling case for like why to
actually put that on I didn't know all
right I'm going to 111 yeah no I well I
think I know I sent me to the wrong room
here really
I'll agree to the vertical all felt that
way that's fair I I'm not always right
so I will give a beer for Andy and Emily
to I just felt like personal reasons
from Alicia and we're Jenna give me the
more specific but anyway it's everyone
who is a good point Alicia gets the
first one here we go alright you just
got a new blu-ray player what movie do
you buy first I am gonna go with okay
otherwise joints but stalker stalker by
Tarkovsky okay yeah I'll tell you why
all right your first Oh Jenni 20 seconds
begins when you begin speaking that's my
favorite movie the whole reason this is
wonderful it's really good and everyone
looks spider-man it has some good lines
and it's a good film
I recommend it in hi-def I guess uncle
ray as special features good music
videos I think there's a Nickelback
music video that comes with it
it was really done big comeback in there
at that point second very specific why
reason why I chose this is because
they've just done a criteria andrey
release of this film where they've added
a whole bunch of extras to the blu-ray
it's a restored version of the film
which looks incredible Tarkovsky is an
incredible like experimental crazy out
there director who creates these
existential nightmares and stalker is
one of these films that I want to see
mr. 10 seconds Jenny if I buy a blu-ray
I'm going to want to watch it a million
times to justify that I feel like I've
watched a stalker one
spider-man you can watch up to a
thousand times and still have it be good
second thousand I think spider-man it
doesn't offer anything new
being on blu-ray there's nothing
specifically exciting that comes with
that wasn't good soundtrack good song
alright Tony you are not going to catch
her this time based on that argument in
the better aspects of the soundtrack I
would have went Spidey but he shalida
gray blu-ray would make stalker better I
was really waiting for kind of the
effects of spider-man how that I would
be that that would benefit in the
high-def blu-ray I got a touch of it but
need a lot a bit more Alicia gave a lot
about why the blu-ray was something the
best Tony you thought likewise she just
like amazing yet not really one of my
yeah we got a few a few use those little
extra seconds a little more you got a
light took you long and gets Nickelback
it's a woman hopefully in that era no
all right here we go number three what
franchise I'm gonna name an actor you
tell us what franchise late to join neck
okay what franchise should Tony rebel re
join next haha really I've been really
fun if you've got names what I would
have is like the one I won franchise
should Tony joined our universe I'm
going to go with Boston serious
Oh talk about with Tony you're not the
judge it your vote we might go to
overrule your moto depending with your
sister's is getting telling your ever
Laurie is why are we playing Sony in the
dark universe I made a lot of mean
arguments against my point so I'd like
to banish him to the dark ages I would
see him playing May
Creature from the Black Lagoon sweetie
brother also horribly deformed what but
it doesn't have as much skill with the
ladies all right all right
interesting tactic there that's my first
time see but I'll accept that yeah
Alicia why you think impressive furious
I think sex box on your filmography has
been too good we need to kind of just
take it down a notch to put you again a
really fun franchise I want to see you I
guess
Vin Diesel I think that would be
hilarious I want to see you with the Dom
I want to see you try and make them
critters or something really good and
I'd love to see you driving cars I think
it would be awesome see you in an act
more of an action movie right now
seconds why don't we want to see the
other one tell me like I said I don't
know it was sorry Jennifer he can wear a
rubber suit in that one more say lines
like I'll get you Wolfman that's a
career-maker
Felicia
yeah I feel like this is a personal
vendetta because I think that would be a
horrible use of Mustela documents I
don't want to say anymore John
definitely off I think you can try but
yeah thank you for getting Tony where
your thoughts men will not rule you are
I'm just curious what I did watch the
show okay or an order ball to now you
were girl what yeah where do you want to
join you want to take your imperial wide
I think a low your personal opinion
aside I hear from the black balloon or
go against Tom I would love to go gun
Dom I want to play as him and so I well
they're both melon balls man are they
really
I don't know
is village all right but you're picking
Dom right doesn't matter anything let's
overall the Yorkshire fans what do you
think is legend Tony as they are like an
intern to the fast crew that eventually
turned basement loving man w guys like
them and fast I well I really like
vengeful argument that was it
interesting yeah I didn't hear as much
about how he's going to make some how
the fast appears yeah it's going to go
against Tom which animal do you think
I'll go with the vegetable I got see the
vegetable was interesting for me Dan you
can be able to break the tie here as a
seasoned Fighter III like to keep the
bulbs up a little bit I sound sort of
low blow and I don't think The Creature
from the Black Lagoon speaks now it's
your brother
dummy do me brother right but those are
allowing personally man you got to win
all the judges we didn't any I was with
you but created to a lesion I think she
was you did I'm alone tell us again when
will you find your book and when did I
fail it comes out the first week of
August it's called back within and heals
it's the history of women in Hollywood I
worked really hard on it so keep quiet
please go buy it go check it out you can
pre-order in Amazon
thank you so much congratulations Lygia
thank next up Tony they got a big got
this weird movie coming up this weekend
yeah yeah baby what is it again okay
well bachelor I play The Creature from
the Black Lagoon no I did go watch
spider-man home coming out tonight
ah please go show your support because I
watching all that redo your movie small
indie mom and it needs it needs your
love these small indie director and oh
man you got a big break
no I really love up I mean I mean you
saw the film you know how small it is in
terms of how could it how big it could
have been so I think that's what people
are gonna really love so please go see
it yeah please also please go buy this
book this over you can see doctrine
support Jenny I want you to do or you
need a better man I got you a job
and the creature in the blind for you
all right together
yeah no videos everyone go see Papa
behind your back yeah good job very much
ginger Jenny yes Malia Falcon on what
we'll be jumping over to screen jockeys
main soon you'll be all watching the
video and they can find you on YouTube
also on your yeah my name Jenny
Nicholson I'm also on other social
medias yeah well there you go
Jenny thank you bringing it today Dan
merle admiral dan on twitter and you got
the fight next week live here 4 p.m. on
you next week we may have a new movie
fights champion who knows and I'm
fighting for the ultimate strode on belt
- as we're airing tomorrow yeah but you
can go check that out it's so what all
the belts are out of line if we all the
belts on all I can have no belts except
for TV fights at the end of this with
what 7 days so I'm excited to do it yes
I'm excited too happens it'll be a very
interesting twist in store so you'll
want to stay tuned and tune in live I'm
going to be a lot of fun
Tom Devon and Devon thank you so much
for coming I hope you had fun watching
today's show I've been watching since
the loggers I mean it's been a blast
this was drinking true for sure Thank
You Man Tom anything you want to plug
well you can find me at rotary or 3:00
on Twitter I do a youtube show called
cars and popcorn where I have a guest on
and we talk about the cars as characters
from various movies and TV that they
select that's special time so check it
out you can follow me on Twitter and I
talk about it all the time oh good I
think we're reviewing movies and cars
was going to say careful don't do that
Devon I think you'd like to plug yeah
you guys can find me on twitter at jesus
12 buy my writing articles for geeks and
gamers and then I have my podcast that
Jesus take the real with a double can
write movies and wife Felicia has been
on before and that sounds a good time
and we don't know how to like games and
tell stories and talk movies love it
thank you guys so much for coming and
make sure you guys enter our screen
duckie central contest screen agiza
complex SJ central let's sign up and
maybe you'll join us a comic-con thanks
Samsung and for doing that the
Chromebook plus and thank you all for
watching at home we will see you next
week for the championship battle live
have a good one
[Music]